my stories about how not to raise your
children this is a 22 year old man from
India he received a brand-new BMW as a
birthday gift he wasn't happy with it
because he wanted a Jaguar so what'd he
do we push the BMW into a river what he
could have just given it to me he pushed
it into a river because he said that's
not the car that he wanted what his
parents said that you know they were
questioned about should they press
charges no there will be no charges the
parents say they say that the they
believe their son has mental health
issues which is what I might say to
another time sounds like affluenza
remember that case the affluenza story
yes it does but it reminds me when
favorite daughter Kirby was three and I
bought everything on her Christmas list
as one does when you don't know any
better
and she opened her the 23rd given set is
that it and I realized that's not the
kind of child I wanted to raise and so
you was a parent send a message so the
fact that he gets a brand-new BMW and
says now I wanted a Jaguar not so good
right that would never happen in the
Smith household you don't think so I
don't think so